last week tsm fired their long-standing
league of legends coach peter zhang for
what they described as a conflict of
interest and unethical practices the
reports that have emerged in the days
since paint a bizarre picture in this
latest chapter of what has been a brutal
year for tsm's league of legends team
alright then if you find these videos
informative or helpful in any way and
you haven't subscribed yet please
consider doing so it would help us get
to two million subs and you would get
our videos sent to you every single day
no worries so on march 18th we knew that
something was going on with tsm's league
of legends team when a couple of the
players started tweeting speakers said
every day at tsm is a banger lol and
later on shen yi tweeted this series of
dots and later tsm released a statement
on twitter saying we were recently made
aware of very serious allegations of
conflict of interest and unethical
practices against league of legends
coach peter zhang after an initial
conversation we have terminated him
effective immediately we are working
with external legal counsel to complete
a full investigation now if you don't
know peter zhang also known as zhang yi
joined tsm as their academy team's head
coach in 2018 and also spent a year as
the main rosters coach before returning
to academy tsm offered no further
explanations about the allegations of
conflict of interest and unethical
practices as speculation exploded peter
zhang addressed tsm fans directly in the
orgs discord he said he made a mistake
which he guessed was enough for him to
get immediately released from the orc
later in a longer post he quelled the
rumor that his dismissal was due to
alleged match fixing he added his
appreciation for tsm and said his plan
was to return to his family in china and
wait for the results of tsm's
investigation lcs commissioner jack
felling confirmed in a reddit comment
that on riot's end this was not a case
of match fixing and that it was an
internal matter for tsm so tsm wasn't
adding anything to their statement for
now and peter zhang was not elaborating
on the details of his dismissal however
on sunday dexato's richard lewis
published an article in which he stated
that sources informed them peter zhang
had been dismissed because of an
agent-style setup where he'd secured
chinese and taiwanese players a spot on
tsm for a cut of their earnings these
sources told dexerto that peter zhang
would take a portion of the player's
earnings usually much higher than a
standard agent's fee and then ensured
that they had a spot on the team if this
was the case it would naturally be a big
conflict of interest to act as both
agent and coach sources also told
dexerto that peter zhang had been
borrowing quote significant sums of
money from many figures under the tsm
organization including players from both
the main and academy roster and that
quote when affected parties raised
concerns about the loans they started to
be paid back at the time of reporting
this almost all the money has been
recouped peter zhang confirmed the
existence of these loans to dexerto and
told them he needed the money for a
family emergency for which he showed
proof of him requesting time off for
this as for the coach agent role he said
the accusations of him playing both
coach and agent were either a
misunderstanding or a malicious framing
of events he cited one example with
tsm's academy support yersen and
admitted that while he did receive a one
thousand dollar a month cut from his
paycheck that money was always sent
directly to the player's agent he
explained that this was because as a us
green card holder he had bank accounts
in both countries and so was able to
facilitate these transactions more
easily now between tsm's announcement
and dexato's article doublelift had
alluded on stream that he knew some of
the details of this story doublelift
tsm's former ad carry has had clashes
with its own original which have led in
part to a recent riot investigation into
the ceo over alleged work misconduct and
bullying of employees doublelift knew
peter zhang from his time at tsm and
when the dexerto article came out he
added some more allegations to the pile
i do not want to say who he has 200k
from but what i will say is that he got
multiple players multiple players on tsm
to send him anywhere between 12 and 25k
and then that same day those players
before that wire transfer went through
those players canceled it and like saved
their money doublelift also alleged that
former tsm support sword art had asked
peter zhang to sell his car for him when
the taiwanese star returned home after a
year with the team at that point i was
like okay this guy he's doing a bunch of
sketchy under the table stuff he owes
this guy like a metric ton of money that
was a super expensive car i knew that he
definitely owed sword art money and i
was like this is
peter zhang told dexerto that he
recognizes his wrongdoing that he will
pay sword art back in full that the
other claims about him are not true and
that he will work with right in any
investigation they conduct to prove his
innocence doublelift also said that
peter zhang had recently asked him for
seventy thousand dollars to cover
medical expenses for his grandma who was
dying in hospital if somebody asked me
in an emergency for a few thousand
dollars or somebody that i really really
trusted i would lend them a pretty large
amount of money seventy thousand someone
i barely know no that's not happening
doublelift added that when he asked some
of their mutual friends he found they've
been asked and told similar things by
peter zhang clearly there's still a lot
that's unknown here there are questions
that only tsm peter zhang all the people
he allegedly asked for money from can
answer and if you've been watching any
of my recent videos on tsm you'll know
that all of this comes after months of
key figures leaving the org while their
famed lcs team has had its worst start
in the league's nine-year history tsm
will likely elaborate on the details of
this dismissal once they've concluded
their report it's unclear whether peter
zhang will do the same beyond the
admissions and denials he's already made
we're certainly missing some details
here details that will help clear up at
least one corner of the room of calamity
that is tsm's 2022 so far
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you